Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Merkst du nicht, dass du anders bist?
- Eigentlich schon.
Aber ich weiss nicht,
was genau anders ist.
Kinder mit Autismus - sie kommen mit
unserem Schulsystem an ihre Grenzen.
Genau wie Lehrpersonen und Eltern.
Man will das Beste fürs Kind.
Man weiss, dass man es dorthin
schickt und es ihm nicht gut geht.
(Frau) Kira regierte in Überforde-
rungssituationen immer mit Schreien.
Sie wäre in einem grossen
Klassenverband einfach überfordert.
(Mann) Er ist im Moment im Flow.
Es wäre ein Fehler, ihm jetzt
den äusseren Rahmen aufzuzwingen.
Oftmals sind Privatschulen der letzte
Ausweg für betroffene Familien.
Da müsste man wirklich von
einem Zweiklassensystem sprechen.
Filmst du jetzt schon? Okay.
- Ja.
Du kannst einfach geradeausschauen,
als wäre ich nicht da.
Kira, 14 Jahre, im Autismusspektrum.
Kira, wie bist du heute Morgen
aufgestanden?
Freust du dich auf die Schule?
Wie ist das?
Der Weg ist etwas lange.
Manchmal ist es etwas kalt.
Wie lange dauert es?
- Meistens ist der Schulweg ...
... um die 1,5 Std.
- Okay.
Ist es schlimm, nicht mehr in deinem
Dorf in die Schule zu gehen?- Äh ...
Eigentlich nicht. Hier
ist es viel besser in der Schule.
Kira kommt aus dem Kanton Thurgau
und besucht eine Privatschule
im zürcherischen Elgg.
Die Endstation einer langen,
unglücklichen Odyssee
durch das Schulsystem.
So gut.
Morgen.
- Hoi.- Morgen.
Hoi, Kira.
Aktuell besuchen
nur gerade drei Kinder
die Schule von Stephan Rusconi
und seiner Frau.
Bist du vorangekommen?
Hast du weiter
an Pythagoras gearbeitet?
Ja, eine Aufgabe.
Oder zwei. Ich weiss es nicht mehr.
Ja, wir schauen.
Gut, Kira, schau ...
- Da ist ein Bleistift drin.
Ich habe ein Dreieck gemacht.
Darf ich schnell die Stifte ...
- Mhm.
Scheisse.
Kira
ist eine extrem sensible Person.
Sie wäre in einem grossen
Klassenverband einfach überfordert.
Sie verarbeitet alles gleichzeitig.
Also,
sie war auch komplett überfordert.
Das war eine grosse Leidenszeit.
- Genau.
Und ja ... Es ist ...
Es kann schwierige Situationen geben
mit Kira.
Wenn sie
in eine totale Überforderung kommt.
Das braucht
einfach einen extremen Fokus,
dass man sie aus dieser Ohnmacht,
die sie auch zeigt,
rausbegleiten kann.
So, jetzt passt es.
- Jetzt noch die Bleistifte.
Also, Kira, schau mal nach vorne.
Ich habe hier ein Dreieck gemacht.
Mhm.
Im Zusammenhang
mit dem Satz des Pythagoras.
Was ist da wichtig?
Ähm ...
Was ist eine Grundvoraussetzung,
um ihn anzuwenden?
Dass man einen rechten Winkel hat.
Gut.
Komm doch mal schnell nach vorne.
Kiras Leiden
an der öffentlichen Schule
begann
mit dem ersten Tag im Kindergarten.
Kira weinte und schrie viel,
wurde nach einem Monat
nach Hause geschickt
und ein Jahr zurückgestellt.
Nach der Autismusdiagnose,
die zusätzlich ADHS zutage förderte,
folgten die Anerkennung
des Sonderschulstatus,
Begleitung durch Klassenassistenzen
und der Aufenthalt
in einer psychiatrischen Tagesklinik.
Du hast es jetzt andersrum gemacht.
- Egal.
Erinnerst du dich:
Beim rechtwinkligen Dreieck
werden die Seiten
speziell bezeichnet.
Die linke ist etwas mit "Hy".
- Jawohl, genau.
Hypotenuse.
- Ja, die Hypotenuse.
Der Schulalltag mit all seinen Reizen
war zu viel für Kira.
Ich weiss noch, dass es
in der Klasse nicht sehr gut ging.
Darum war ich
in einem kleinen Raum ...
Keine Ahnung, wie viele ... 1-2 m2.
Da wurde ich eingesperrt
und machte meine Aufgaben.
Du warst getrennt von den anderen?
- Der Raum war wirklich winzig.
Jemand mit Klaustrophobie
könnte da nicht drinsitzen.
Wie war es für dich,
dort zu arbeiten?
Nicht so cool.
Die Lehrerin kam alle 10-20 Min.,
um zu helfen.
Wenn ich Hilfe brauchte,
konnte ich nicht nach vorne gehen.
Dann musste ich 10 Min. nichts tun.
So konnte ich
auch fast nicht lernen.
Wie lief es vom Sozialen her mit
den Mitschülerinnen und Mitschülern?
Es geht so. Meistens
war ich in der Pause allein.
Warum?
- Keine Ahnung.
Sie wollten
einfach nicht mit mir spielen.
Und du wolltest?
- Eigentlich schon. Aber sie nicht.
In der Schule "Scola Anima Nova"
werden Kinder unterrichtet,
die durch sämtliche Maschen
unseres Schulsystems gefallen sind.
Einige sind Kinder
im Autismusspektrum wie Kira,
die oft monatelang
keine Schule mehr besuchten.
Finanziert wird Kiras Schulbesuch
vom Kanton Thurgau.
Kira hat diese letzte Chance gepackt.
Doch auch hier
bringt sie ihre Lehrpersonen
manchmal noch an ihre Grenzen.
Wenn man Kira, wie ich das mache,
begleitet und beobachtet,
würde man nicht denken,
dass sie manchmal anders sein kann.
Aber das kann sie, oder?
- Das stimmt.
Ich gebe mir eigentlich Mühe.
- Sehr.
Das ist tatsächlich so.
Wir erleben Kira gerade als ...
Ja ...
... ganz entspannt ...
... heiter und ausgeglichen.
So lernten wir sie
aber nicht kennen.
Bei der ersten Begegnung mit Kira
ging es auch um einen Cappuccino.
Sie lag am Boden
und zappelte wie ein wildes ...
... Tier.
Sie wollte mir beweisen,
was ein Cappuccino ist.
Das habe ich fast vergessen.
Ich weiss, dass ich am Boden sass,
aber dass es
um einen Kaffee ging ...
Um den Cappuccino für deine Mami.
Ich wollte dir
einen Kindercappuccino anbieten.
Und du fandest,
es gebe nur Cappuccino.
Kira hat wirklich
einen langen Weg hinter sich.
Oder?
Früher
schrie sie wirklich jeden Tag.
So laut, dass wir sagten:
"Das halten wir nicht mehr aus."
Wir wussten aber, dass wir
das hinkriegen wollten mit Kira.
Damit sie ohne Schreien
zu sich kommen kann.
Und sie hat es geschafft.
Das ist erstaunlich.
- Wodurch schaffte sie das?
Ja ...
Aus meiner Sicht
ist der grösste Teil das Vertrauen.
Es braucht viel Geduld.
Und auch Reflexion.
Und manchmal
muss man sie ausschreien lassen.
Aber wir tolerieren nicht mehr,
dass sie dort schreit, wo wir sind.
Dann muss sie in einen anderen Raum.
Ich habe
nur das als Schokolade gefunden.
Das kannst du nehmen.
- Stephan?
Ich rede noch.
- Ich frage ja Stephan.
Stimmt, aber ich bin hier ...
Es braucht einfach Geduld
und auch ...
... ein Eingeständnis von ihr,
dass es so nicht geht.
Autismus - genauer
Autismus-Spektrum-Störung, ASS -
ist genetisch bedingt.
1-5 % der Bevölkerung sind betroffen.
Die genauen Ursachen
sind nicht vollständig geklärt.
Was aber klar ist:
Kinder im Spektrum
sind nicht schlecht erzogen.
Was für ein Würfel ist das?
(Junge) Das ist der Megaminx 3x3x12,
glaube ich.
Die meisten Leute
können den gar nicht lösen.
Ich könnte das nie.
Das ist auch deine Erfahrung, oder?
- Ja.
Ich habe ein YouTube-Tutorial
geschaut. Dann ging es.
Nino Diem, 12 Jahre.
Nino hat das Aspergersyndrom,
eine Ausprägung von Autismus.
Zu viele Reize und neue Situationen
sind schwierig für ihn.
Für mich ist es schwierig, wenn
jemand z.B. an meinem Platz sitzt.
Weil ich dort sitzen will.
Oder ...
Ich brauche
immer wieder mal Ordnung.
Wenn wir z.B.
in einem Restaurant sind ...
... wo megaviele Leute
durcheinander sprechen ...
Das ist megaschwierig für mich,
weil ich wie überall mithöre.
Ich kann mich dann nicht
auf ein Gespräch fokussieren.
Dann werde ich sehr schnell müde,
es kackt mich an und es ist doof.
Nino ist das dritte Kind
von Tanja Diem und ihrem Mann.
Heitere Gespräche nach der Schule -
für Ninos Mutter
noch immer ein Geschenk.
Was habt ihr am ersten Tag gemacht?
Wir gingen in die Schule.
- Ah.
Dann hatten wir Klassenstunde
und ich dann R&C.
Danach Englisch und danach Science.
Dann war wieder Pause. Mittagspause.
Dann hatten wir noch Mathe,
dann Französisch
und dann noch mal Französisch.
Ja.
Gut.
- War das heute ein guter Tag?
Ja.
In den öffentlichen Schulen
war es jeweils nicht so gut.
Keine Ahnung.
- Weisst du das nicht mehr?
Wissen Sie noch,
wie er jeweils nach Hause kam?
Ja ...
Oft wollte er gar nicht erst gehen.
Oder ging auch nicht.
Er weinte viel.
Oft kam er halt
frustriert nach Hause.
Und dann:
Ein falsches Wort an Ninos Adresse,
sein Teller am falschen Platz
und die Situation eskalierte.
Abend für Abend.
Es war sehr schwierig.
Man musste nur etwas Kleines sagen
und schon war es nicht mehr gut.
Dann explodierte Nino wirklich,
sprang auf ...
... der Stuhl kippte
und er rastete aus und schrie.
Dann ging er nach oben
und ass nichts mehr.
Dann assen wir zu viert zu Abend
und es gab eine unangenehme Stille.
Ich bin froh,
dass die Zeiten vorbei sind.
Nino, wie ist das,
wenn man so über dich spricht?
Geht das für dich?
- Ja.
Ist das unangenehm?
- Nein. Ich brauche ein Jogurt.
Wenn er so ausgerastet ist ...
... versuchten wir oft ...
... "Regeln" abzumachen,
wenn man das so nennen kann:
Dass er nur seine Dinge kaputtmacht.
Wenn es wieder gut war ...
... gingen wir regelmässig
mit einem Abfallsack ...
... in sein Zimmer und warfen
alles weg, was kaputt war.
Irgendwann hatte es nichts mehr
und es erübrigte sich.
Der Fünfjährige war in grosser Not.
Die erste Diagnose: Depression.
Er hat
zwei Suizidversuche hinter sich.
Die waren in der ersten Klasse.
Er kam zu uns und fragte:
"Ist mein Leben weniger wert?"
Dann setzte er sich im Zimmer
auf die Fensterbank
und machte Anstalten,
dass er aufhören wolle.- Mhm.
Christoph
konnte ihn von der Fensterbank holen
und ich beim zweiten Mal vom Balkon.
Er flehte uns mit fünf an,
dass wir ihm helfen,
wieder in den Himmel zu kommen.
Er sei hier am falschen Ort.
Es war der Schulalltag,
der Nino so zusetzte -
zu laut, zu unstrukturiert,
zu chaotisch für ihn.
Zu langweilig auch
für den intelligenten Jungen.
Von seiner Autismus-Spektrum-Störung
wusste damals noch niemand.
Er hat in der Schule
nie rebelliert.
Er hat sich nie falsch verhalten.
Er machte immer alles,
was man verlangte.
Sie konnten
kein schlechtes Wort über ihn sagen.
Sie hätten gerne mehr solche Kinder,
die so funktionierten.
Wir als Eltern waren die,
die ihn nicht im Griff hatten.
Beatrice Gnaegi berät Eltern
von Kindern im Autismusspektrum.
Autisten
reagieren sehr unterschiedlich
auf die Herausforderungen
des Schulalltags.
Zwei Haupttypen zeigen sich dennoch:
Der eine Typ
ist eher der Oppositionelle,
der nach aussen
etwas aggressiver wird.
Das ist häufig
in der Schule zu beobachten.
Das sind meistens Jungs.
Es gibt Ausnahmen,
aber tendenziell sind es eher Jungs,
die so auffällig werden und stören.
Dann finden die Lehrer schnell:
"So geht es nicht."
Oder: "Da liegt was vor.
Wir müssen das abklären."
Dann nimmt das seinen Lauf.
Das Verstecktere,
was aber auch häufig der Fall ist:
Dass man gegen aussen
sehr angepasst ist.
Das nennt man auch Maskieren.
Man weiss ja,
was erwartet wird und korrekt wäre.
Es braucht eine so hohe Leistung,
um diese Rolle zu spielen.
Also,
das Theater aufrechtzuerhalten.
Wenn sie nach Hause kommen,
fällt die Maske dann ab.
Und dann geht nichts mehr.
Da lernt man
wie zwei verschiedene Kinder kennen.
Die Schule sieht leider
nur den Teil in der Schule
und die Eltern den Teil zu Hause.
Und die passen nicht zusammen.
Nino war der ruhige Typ
und ein Meister des Maskierens.
Zu Hause rebellierte er.
Seine Eltern suchten das Gespräch
mit Lehrpersonen und Schulbehörden,
erzählten offen
von den Zuständen zu Hause.
Hilfe bekamen sie keine.
Oft hiess es,
in der Schule funktioniere es.
"Wir können mit ihm."
"Ihr habt wohl
ein Problem zu Hause."
Und ...
Also, wir hatten definitiv
ein Problem zu Hause.
Ich will auch nicht sagen,
dass wir alles perfekt machten
und man es nur so machen sollte.
Gar nicht.
Aber ...
... wir brauchten Hilfe
und eine Veränderung.
Dann wäre es anders gekommen.
Es ist nicht,
dass wir nie an uns zweifelten.
Wir fragten uns oft,
was wir wohl falsch machen.
"Wie könnten wir es
noch anders machen?"
Es war nicht nur streng für ihn,
sondern auch für uns.
Wir gingen manchmal durch die Hölle.
Die Hölle - das waren Suizidgedanken,
Ess- und Schlafstörungen bei Nino
und Selbstzweifel, Angst
und Überforderung bei den Eltern.
Und Geschwister, die beinahe mit Nino
zusammen untergegangen wären.
Ein ganzes Familiensystem
drohte zu zerbrechen.
Beatrice Gnaegi
kennt solche Geschichten zur Genüge.
In ihrer Facebook-Gruppe
erzählen mittlerweile 680 Mitglieder
von ihren Leidensgeschichten
mit dem Schweizer Schulsystem.
Mit bisweilen dramatischen Wendungen.
Am Schluss
sind die Eltern erziehungsunfähig.
Dann gibt es
eine Gefährdungsmeldung an die KESB.
Und beruhend auf Gutachten,
die z.T. die Diagnose absprachen ...
Also, da hiess es dann:
"Nein, da liegt kein Autismus vor."
Und deswegen wurde entschieden, den
Eltern das Obhutsrecht zu entziehen.
Weil sie angeblich nicht fähig sind
und nicht auf die Bedürfnisse
des Kindes eingehen.
Das ist dann massiv.
- Wurden da Kinder weggenommen?
Ja. Tatsächlich.
Dann muss man mit Anwälten kommen
und beweisen,
dass die Diagnose doch stimmt.
Dann braucht es ein Gegengutachten
und das muss genehmigt werden.
Das ist ein riesiger Aufwand.
Das macht alle kaputt.
Die Kinder sowieso
und die Eltern auch.
Man ist in einer riesigen Ohnmacht.
Kira ist nicht
das einzige autistische Kind
ihrer alleinerziehenden Mutter
Jael Seidenberg.
Auch Kiras jüngerer Bruder Aric
ist im Spektrum.
Das Kinn ist voll.
- Dann putz es kurz ab.
Es hat ja ein Waschbecken.
- Haben wir Servietten?
Frau Seidenberg, mit zwei
autistischen Kindern wird es ...
(Kira) Aric ist minimal autistisch.
... nicht langweilig.
Das ist anstrengend, oder?
Das ist manchmal sehr anstrengend.
Was sind
die grössten Herausforderungen?
Dass sie manchmal zur gleichen Zeit
völlig verschiedene Bedürfnisse
haben
und man gleichzeitig an zwei Orten
etwas ganz anderes machen sollte.
Das ist die grösste Herausforderung.
Kiras Probleme in der Regelschule
eskalierten nach dem Lockdown.
Sie weigerte sich,
in die Schule zurückzukehren
und
wurde in eine Sonderschule versetzt,
wo man sie nach einem Tag
wieder nach Hause schickte.
Jetzt ging Kira
gar nicht mehr zur Schule.
Die ganze Situation hat alle
Familienmitglieder extrem belastet.
Ich musste schauen,
dass es allen einigermassen geht.
"Gut geht"
konnte man wie nicht mehr sagen.
Dass alle irgendwie überleben. Ja.
Der Druck
wurde mir irgendwann zu viel, ja.
Wie hat sich das geäussert?
Depression, Burn-out ...
Man sagte mir,
es sei eine Erschöpfungsdepression.
Okay.
Aric!
* Ruhige Klänge *
Hier habe ich das Aquarium.
Was mit Kira und ihrem Umfeld
passiert, wenn sie unter Druck gerät,
erfahre ich gleich darauf selbst.
Wir haben vereinbart,
dass ich ihr Aquarium filme.
Die kleinen, gestreiften Fische
sind Zebrabärblinge.
Das ist ein Gruppenfisch.
Darum habe ich so viele.
Die fühlen sich in Gruppen wohler.
Und ...
Ich habe auch viele Guppys.
Der Blaue z.B. ist auch einer.
Besteht eine Ähnlichkeit
zwischen dir und den Fischen?
Sind sie dir darum so sympathisch?
- Ich glaube nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube, Fische beruhigen besser.
Wir können schauen,
wo die Babyfische sind.
Bist du manchmal nervös?
Wenn ... Ja, jetzt ...
Oh, da hinten ist einer.
Ein Babyfisch.
Willst du sie nicht filmen?
Ich möchte wissen,
ob du manchmal nervös bist.
Ja, sehr oft halt.
Was macht dich so nervös?
- Keine Ahnung. Frag mich nicht.
Was nervt dich?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Ich will das nicht beantworten.
Ich bin bei den Fischen.
Soll ich die Fische filmen?
- Du kannst ja Mami fragen.
Ich dachte,
ich könne die Fische zeigen.
Aber jetzt doch nicht, oder was?
Wie würdest du dich beschreiben?
Was ist an dir anders
als bei anderen 14-Jährigen?
Es ist schwierig,
das zu beschreiben.
Ich muss immer
megastark darüber nachdenken,
wenn mir jemand
so eine Frage stellt.
Das ist mir zu anstrengend.
- Denkst du nicht gerne darüber nach?
Ja.
- Aha.
Noch mal zu den Fischen:
Das ist ein Thema, bei dem du ...
Ich merke es selber nicht so.
Merkst du nicht, dass du anders bist?
- Eigentlich schon.
Aber ich weiss nicht,
was genau anders ist.
Es ist schwierig,
das von sich zu sagen.
Was sagen die anderen Leute?
Keine Ahnung. Frag sie doch selber.
- Mhm.
Ähm ...
Ich muss auf meinen Spick schauen.
Du kannst dir ja selbst
eine eigene Meinung dazu bilden,
was an mir anders ist.
Warum musst du mich fragen?
Wieso ...
Sag, was nervt dich?
Wieso du über dich sprechen musst?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Es nervt mich einfach.- Mhm.
Es ist einfach
enorm anstrengend für mich.
Also, dann hören wir auf.
Dann hören wir auf, Kira.
Ich würde gerne Fragen beantworten,
aber irgendwie mag ich nicht,
weil mir nichts einfällt.
Vielleicht
stelle ich die falschen Fragen.
Worüber würdest du gerne sprechen?
- Ich weiss es nicht.
Ja. Sollen wir Pause machen?
- Ja.- Ja.
Kindertagesschule KiTs
in Bronschhofen.
Hier
hat auch Nino seinen Platz gefunden.
Nino?
- Ja?
Woran arbeitest du als Nächstes?
Machen wir etwas Mathe?
- Daran. Dachte ich.
Willst du daran arbeiten? Okay.
- Mhm.
Seit Mitte der 1. Klasse
besucht Nino diese Privatschule,
die auf Kinder mit
durchschnittlicher bis hoher Begabung
spezialisiert ist.
Hier wird Ninos Bedürfnis nach Ruhe
und Struktur Rechnung getragen.
Nino ist wieder fröhlich.
"Wie könntest du eine Themenfin..."
"... Themenhinführung gestalten?"
"Notiere mind. drei Ideren."
"Ideen".
Eigentlich wollten Sie jetzt
mit Nino arbeiten.- Genau.
Warum machen Sie es nicht?
-Er ist noch am Thema Deutsch.
Er fand, er brauche 15 Min.,
braucht jetzt aber länger.
Er hat aber selber gesagt,
er sei im Flow.
Er hat seine Lernziele
für Ende Woche.
Wir müssen es nützen,
wenn er im Flow ist.
Gerade im Aspergerspektrum
ist das so ein Punkt.
Sie brauchen z.T. länger,
um in den Flow zu kommen.
Wenn sie drin sind,
sind sie aber sehr effizient.
Es wäre ein Fehler, ihm
den äusseren Rahmen aufzuzwingen.
Das Schulgeld von 25'000 Fr. pro Jahr
müssen Ninos Eltern -
nach einem langen Rechtstreit mit
den Schulbehörden - allein stemmen.
Mit diesem Schritt
wollen sie ihrem Sohn
eine erschöpfende
und frustrierende Schulodyssee
wie jene von Kira ersparen.
Auch Ninos Klassenkamerad Gianluca
hat das Aspergersyndrom.
Er kam
aus einer Sonderschule in die KiTs.
Dort war im Prinzip nicht gut,
dass erstens ...
Die Kinder waren dort mehr oder
weniger einfach ausser Kontrolle.
Der Schulleiter dort
verlor sehr schnell den Faden.
Besser gesagt,
er verlor die Beherrschung
und wurde laut.
Und die Kinder dort
benahmen sich extrem asozial.
Das war gar nicht gut.
Es war wirklich einfach mühsam.
Die Schulleitung der KiTs
kennt viele Eltern von Autisten,
insbesondere von Aspergern,
welche lieber
die Kosten einer Privatschule tragen
als ihre Kinder
in eine Sonderschule zu schicken.
Ein Aspergerkind braucht Ruhe.
Ein Aspergerkind
braucht gute Vorbilder.
Es muss ja sehr lange lernen,
um das zu verstehen,
was für uns selbstverständlich ist -
das Emotionale.
Es wird nur lernen,
sich emotional einigermassen
angepasst zu verhalten,
wenn es lernen kann zu spiegeln usw.
Wenn es in einem Umfeld ist,
in dem Kinder
mit anderen Schwierigkeiten sind,
lernt es das schwierige Verhalten.
Das ist meine Theorie. Und ...
Die Asperger
sind oft sehr intelligent.
Da braucht es eine Schule
für hochintelligente Kinder.
Es braucht eine Schule,
die Ruhe gibt.
die ein Verständnis
für das Autismusspektrum hat.
Eine Sonderschule,
wie wir sie üblicherweise verstehen,
kann das in der Regel nicht.
Ninos Eltern
und Gianlucas alleinerziehender Vater
verzichten
auf Ferien und jeglichen Luxus,
um ihren Kindern die passende Art
der Beschulung zu ermöglichen.
Vielen anderen betroffenen Familien
gelingt dies nicht.
Kommt hinzu:
Die Schulgemeinden handhaben
die Finanzierung von Privatschulen
völlig unterschiedlich.
Wir reden immer
von Chancengleichheit
und auch Nachteilsausgleich usw.
Das findet nur bedingt statt.
Es ist tatsächlich so,
dass man von einem Zweiklassensystem
sprechen muss.
Die einen haben Glück und es geht
und andere haben Pech
und können das nicht finanzieren.
Die müssen irgendwie durch die
Regel- oder Sonderschulzeit kommen.
Mit welchen Folgen
für die betroffenen Kinder?
Ich würde das nicht nur von
der Schule selbst abhängig machen.
Wenn das Setting nicht passt -
egal welches -,
kommt es häufig
zu Folgeerkrankungen.
Man nennt das Komorbiditäten.
Ängste, Zwänge, häufig
auch Depressionen im Jugendalter.
Schulverweigerung
ist auch oft ein Thema.
Dann wird es schwierig.
Wie geht es dann weiter?
Was braucht es?
Dann kommen
die Therapien oder Psychiatrien.
Kinder im Autismusspektrum
und die Regelschule -
meist keine Liebesbeziehung.
Doch die Integration
kann auch gelingen.
Diese 2. Klasse
der öffentlichen Schule Waldkirch
besucht auch ein Kind im Spektrum,
dieses ist heute aber nicht anwesend.
Autismusexpertin Bettina Blättler
klärt die Klassenkameraden auf.
Manchmal ...
... macht jemand z.B. Dinge ...
... die ihr vielleicht
nicht so nett findet.
Gab es das auch schon?
- (Kinder) Ja.
Mhm.
Das ist,
weil sie vielleicht nicht weiss,
wie euer Spiel funktioniert.
Oder wie es richtig geht.
Ich glaube, sie möchte sehr gerne
in Kontakt mit euch sein
und etwas mit euch machen.
Aber diese speziellen Kinder
wissen manchmal einfach nicht,
wie das geht.
Darum machen sie es manchmal
auf eine komische Art.
Z.B. mit Schubsen.
(Kinder) Boah!
- Hm?
Kennt ihr das? Ja?
Ihr sprecht ja dann mit ihr.
Ihr sagt: "Hör auf."
Oder: "Was machst du?"
Sie hat ja den Kontakt mit euch.
Autismus-Spektrum-Störung - ASS.
Viele Schulbehörden
sehen darin eine Modediagnose,
betroffene Kinder und Jugendliche
als Produkt erziehungsunfähiger
Eltern oder von Familienkonflikten.
Doch es gibt auch Schulbehörden,
die mehr wissen
und mit der Inklusion ernst machen.
Ich glaube, es muss alles stimmen.
Wir haben eine Schulleitungsführung,
der es wichtig war,
dass ich geschult werde.
Sie holten Frau Blättler ins Team
und ich konnte mich in den
Sommerferien mit ihr austauschen.
Ich war
an einer Autismus-Weiterbildung ...
Man muss als Lehrperson wissen,
worum es geht.
Logisch gab es Situationen,
in denen ich völlig überfordert war.
Aber man wächst auch
an der Situation.
Es beginnt bei der Haltung.
Dass man sagt: "Wir machen etwas."
"Es ist uns wichtig, die Kinder
gut zu integrieren und beschulen."
Und das Zweite sind die Finanzen.
Dass man Klassenassistenzen
und Heilpädagogikstunden haben kann.
Und dass man
die vorhandenen Heilpädagogikstunden
nicht einfach den Kindern gibt
und es dann anderswo fehlt.
Dass mehr über die Finanzierung
gesprochen werden kann.
Dann könnte
ganz viel abgefangen werden,
worunter die Kinder jetzt leiden
und wodurch sie Stress haben.
Die Experten sind sich einig:
Es braucht mehr Institutionen
für Kinder im Autismusspektrum -
klein, überschaubar,
auf die Bedürfnisse
von Kindern wie Kira abgestimmt.
Diese
hat noch ein Schuljahr vor sich.
Danach
möchte Kira mit den Händen arbeiten,
vielleicht Gärtnerin werden.
Das, was jetzt
in Kira investiert wird -
emotional, sozial
und auch finanziell -,
wird sich hundertprozentig
auszahlen.
Denken Sie, dass sie als Erwachsene
ihren Weg machen wird?
Ja.
Wie sie ihn macht,
ob in einer Partnerschaft,
in einer WG oder allein ...
... werden wir sehen.
Aber sie wird ihren Weg
ganz sicher machen.
Ich bin überzeugt,
dass du eine Lehre machen wirst,
die dir entspricht und gefällt.
Daraufhin arbeiten wir.
Ich habe noch nicht geschnuppert.
Aber ich gehe bald.- Genau.
Im Frühling ist etwas in Aussicht.
So,
wie du dich jetzt entwickelt hast,
können wir mit einem sehr guten
Gefühl darauf zurückkommen,
wenn der Frühling da ist.
Dann fragen wir: "Wäre es möglich,
dass Kira schnuppern kommt?"
Nino möchte ans Gymnasium.
Und wenn das nicht klappen sollte,
plant er später
eine Lehre im Detailhandel.
Vorerst ist er aber einfach froh,
dass ich mich mit meiner Kamera
aus seinem Alltag zurückziehe.
Für dich ist es nicht so toll,
dass ich dich filme.
Trotzdem hast du dich
dazu entschieden mitzumachen. Warum?
Es gibt Leute, die ...
... dasselbe haben wie ich.
Aber es geht ihnen richtig schlecht.
Mir geht es jetzt eigentlich gut.
So können die vielleicht
eine Lösung finden.
Autisten sind mitten unter uns - in
jedem Schulhaus, in vielen Klassen.
Mind. eine von hundert Personen
ist betroffen.
Autisten leiden, wenn über
ihre Bedürfnisse hinweggegangen wird.
Und sie blühen auf, wenn sie
in ihrem Element sein dürfen.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023